this is an uprising
a popular Rebellion against the clerics
and rulers of Iran
Mass acts of protest following the death
of a woman called Massa amini
the police arrested her for violating
the rules for wearing her headscarf
inappropriately
then she mysteriously died
in response women here have burnt their
hijabs have tossed them away with
contempt
we'll cut their hair in public each one
is a criminal offense
from a city called karage dancing on her
social media feed
bright and Lively she found freedom on
the internet but the 22 year old wanted
more from her life
and on her way to a protest she posted
this video to her friends in the end
I'll be happy I went to a demo when
everything's changed she said
but by attending a demonstration Ms
najafi was taking a risk
the Iranian president blames some people
for causing chaos a situation he says he
will not allow
Ed and the police have moved in with
clubs and sticks and live ammunition
this video was shot in the center of
Courage on the evening msnajafi walked
to town
she was killed on the same city street
shot in the chest neck and face by what
appears to be a shotgun
mother Suzanne was distraught
the police say Masa amini died of a
heart attack although few believe it
while the najafis were ordered to lie
they say about the cause of hadas's
death we spoke to a family friend after
the burial
the authorities threatened him telling
her parents to say Harris was in a car
accident or that she had died from a
brain injury that she died a natural
death
[Applause]
[Music]
more than 76 people have lost their
lives in wave upon wave of unrest
and the clerics who run this country are
clearly rattled
there's a new generation of people from
Iran who no longer want them in charge
John Sparks Sky News